okay but first up he was just re-elected
to his third term as US Rep from
California's 15th and it's his birthday
congressman Eric swell okay what was
your wish to be with my family but if I
can't be with them I want to be with the
real time yeah you must really want to
be President because it's your birthday
and you're here on my show that's right
and it's how many and at 38 38 oh wow
wow that's know that makes you a Scorpio
I'm Scorpio you believe in astrology no
no no it's a walk you got my vote
[Applause]
okay so you were in Iowa recently I was
you like corn that's you and I like
celebrating and we won the two
congressional seats there I know but
there's these baits where I go to that
one and we almost won this the seat
where I was born to beat Steve King and
we're gonna get him next oh you were
born and I yeah by accident of birth
yeah okay but I mean you are talked
about as someone who might be running
you would be the youngest president ever
if you were the president in 2021 yeah
and what I've gone to Iowa for is to
help us you know put two new candidates
in place but also I am considering it
and I think our country needs new energy
new ideas and a new confidence and
people in Iowa
the people in the heartland or along the
coast they believe that if you work hard
it should add up to something that you
do better for yourself and dream bigger
for your kids and right now we have a
Trump slump top-floor economy where it
only works for people who work on the
top floor and everyone else is just
getting screwed but how do you win a
state like Iowa I mean Obama won it the
first time right you want Indiana to and
a bunch of other rights okay there's
some Democrats just seem to have the key
to it Amy Klobuchar Minnesota is not
always easy sherrod Brown a John tester
mansion in West Virginia what is that
secret to that take the toxic miss out
of the D next to your name and so much
of the middle of this country you got to
show up and listen I'm the son of two
Republicans
my brothers are cops or Republicans I
worked as a prosecutor in law
enforcement so I understand what a lot
of them care about which i think is what
you and I care about which again is that
right now too many families are seeing
their health care protections gutted
they're seeing they're working hard and
they're paying for tax cuts at the top
their communities aren't being invested
in by accident I think Donald Trump's
stumbled on to a lot of these issues
people who felt like they're
disconnected weren't seen weren't heard
but he's not delivering for them I don't
think you have to insult those people
you just have to tell them how you're
going to deliver for them so how would
you deliver for them modern schools in
every community once and for all
once and for all join the rest of the
first world and have a healthcare
guarantee in our country because now the
Democrats kind of ran on health care for
this election and it worked and it was
Nancy Pelosi not only her idea to do
that
she was the architect well she got it
passed Obamacare you know I mean the
pre-existing conditions thing which
really resonated with a lot of people
because they have pre-existing
conditions so now a lot of people wanted
in your party seem to want to dump her
I've heard talk like well we have other
qualified women I mean doesn't have to
be a woman right I mean we're it has to
be the most qualified person I was
decisive leader we had right I mean and
she was the architect of the Affordable
Care Act these candidates ran on
protecting health care and that was top
of mind at the ballot box and if we're
gonna protect what Donald Trump has
taken a wrecking ball to we need her
there leading us and for people who say
that they know the argument was Nancy
Pelosi is a drag on Congress and we're
not gonna win as many seats this is the
biggest pickup for Democrats since
Watergate so why this well why does
Kevin McCarthy get promoted right and
you're gonna fire Nancy Pelosi also a
yes she's effective she's proved that
also whoever is in that job they're
going to trash they're going to try to
make as look as shitty as possible
that's right why not use her because
she's already pre tarnished why ruin up
why ruin a whole new person
and we saw this I saw this in yeah
2002 right you saw Max Cleland three
rivals amputee they turned them into
Osama bin Laden they're not going to
canonize you just because you're now the
person in the chair I think it's a
mistake to replace her we should be
uniting right now there's a lot of work
to do for the American people
okay so I've read your tweets after the
election and you know you were saying to
Donald Trump kind of right in your face
welcome to democracy you know we have
oversight now but it's only the house
it's not the Senate what can you really
do protect the country know how well I
mean I get it that you can subpoena
stuff and you can have witnesses I
you can't impeach him because you don't
have the Senate they have to convict
there's not 67 senators so you're not
gonna impeach him right right we're
gonna investigate where the Republicans
are unwilling to investigate but for the
last two years have been defined by just
panic and outrage by everything that
he's done and trampled on our democracy
in the rule of law now because people
cared and they went to town halls and
town squares and marched they voted to
put a check on these abuses of power so
when you protect health care we can
protect paychecks make sure that no more
people are paying for folks at the top
but most importantly we can protect our
democracy and investigate where they
were unwilling to so presidential
immunity that's over but if people don't
care about the findings I mean like the
New York Times did an exhaustive search
on his tax returns or what he paid in
taxes and how he got his money and it
was an amazing result that they found
I'm he's his whole origin story was a
lie he said I started with a little
pittance from my father maybe a million
dollars he got over 400 million dollars
from his father no one cared why would
why would they care when you throw
another bunch of evidence on the pile
that he's a crook because we're gonna
see his tax returns the American people
will know if the president hears rancid
we'll see as tax affairs gonna be you
know what's gonna be shady you know it's
gonna be this shell companies it's gonna
be very hard to it's not gonna say right
there he cheated and people are gonna go
yeah he's smart he got out of paying
taxes I'd love to do that too
but if he promises that he's gonna make
their life better because he did so in
his own personal career and it turns out
that that was all a fraud people are
gonna care they want to know if the
president is a tax cheat and they also
want to know if it's affecting our
national security we have seen decisions
on Russia decisions in Saudi Arabia they
are being driven because of his prior
financial interest so again those days
are over
we can now intervene interdict and just
stop the president from cashing in on
access to even if he has the Attorney
General I mean I feel like this Matthew
Whitaker story is not getting what it
should it was last week story it's still
an outrage this week that he put a
stooge in there this is what third-world
dictators do I know Democrats too
thrilled hey we have divert we got an
Eskimo he got the Attorney General right
and we're not our 'less anymore though
and I've tried to you know encourage my
colleagues that if this had happened and
we weren't in the majority we should be
panicked but now let's project
confidence and tell the American people
you elected us to stop this we're gonna
stop this and so we're gonna protect Bob
Moeller we're gonna make sure that this
hired assassin who was brought in to
take out the Moller investigation is not
able to do it and also we're gonna do
all we can to get him to recuse himself
because he's prejudged the investigation
and he's been plotting for months with
donald trump to do this so the american
people have spoken
they want a balance of power over an
abuse of power okay
I'm glad that you guys took the house
how many seats you're gonna thinking
I've like 38 39 close to 40 that's a lot
almost all of California even Orange
County Digital California yeah my final
question do we really need to Dakota's
I've seen I bring this up quite often
but you know I mean it's not fair that
California with 40 million people gets
two senators and Dakotas with about
800,000 people get four and I think
that's where we start to reform you
could start that congressman well if I
want a good Thanksgiving with my mom who
is born in South Dakota I'll say yes but
we should start going back to the
Dakotas because we have had Democratic
senators there again right can win in
Kansas we just did we can win in
Nebraska and over there you go half
before so
[Applause]
you